Ben is back in select theaters on
December 7th starring Julia Roberts and
this man who is tremendous in the People
vs OJ Simpson American crime story and
every single thing that he's been in
from hamburger hill to the Hunt for Red
October and more good to see you
Courtney B Vance feedback on your
wonderful show
thank you soon here at wonderful
furniture I appreciate that I appreciate
you complimenting the furniture sir I
appreciate that you've been in that
chair before you were here promoting the
People vs OJ Simpson yeah last time you
were here and so now you're back you're
from Detroit you here in the Detroit
area I am and you left the Lions a long
time ago the lines loved you or what
happened I love my city and but the
Lions are struggling they've been
struggling for a while and I just had to
I had to move on yes you had to find
your win somewhere else and my win
somewhere else and and you know I really
like a culture of winning and people who
will do anything they within the bounds
of what is legal okay to win and I you
know we were just talking earlier about
that that Patriots game in that Green
Bay game where two teams didn't panic
back-to-back nights back-to-back nights
they didn't panic then it's and that was
it was almost like a precursor to a
Super Bowl type feeling because they
they both knew both teams both sets of
teams knew what was at stake and they
they and they were kept raising the
stakes and kept raising the stakes it
also helps to have their number 12 at
the disposal you know Brady in Rogers
you know but it's really about that
culture of surrounding the consistently
no matter what happens win lose or draw
they people leave and and the the the
organization continually surrounds
number 12 yes with the great defense
great offensive line to be the great
kickoff team and punting it so they a
specialty team they continually surround
with whatever they need to make sure
that they win so you're a Patriots fan
I'm a Patriots fan then a Patriots fan
since Drew Bledsoe came back and didn't
come back in a good way
okay and Tom took over okay so that's
when you decided you know you're yeah
but on the Patriots I've been with him
good job that's his time it's a good
time to jump on there that's uh you know
just you could tell that there was
something about this gentleman the
gentleman that it's at and the Chiefs he
is the same feeling Jimmy Holmes he's a
real deal
that's a hell of a game Sunday night I
said you know yeah I know I know that
you know there's the sometimes it's good
to see a defensive game but just
watching a 24 year old kid and Brady at
41 go at it like that 43 40 final that
was amazing nothing you know it's the
middle of the season but both teams knew
they the Patriots knew they couldn't go
down three and three yeah and they and
Kansas City knew that we don't we're not
gonna allow them to be that close to us
four and two and us five and one right
so it was they they were battling it was
like a super that's fun that is fun like
that where do you take these games at
home home okay well yeah that's worth
note you know wherever I can cuz I
wasn't at home
Oh cuz in Detroit you ever joined some
voter registration and to try to went
back to Detroit to try to light a fire
under under the the city okay so I went
to bounce in two days went to about six
or seven series are you knocking on
doors Courtney Vance he's knocking on
door yes I was little in the door and
there you are with a voter registration
some churches I was at community centers
I was with the senator and the
lieutenant governor candidate with
people who are about to go and knock on
doors and written them all inspired
about how important this is life and
death
mm-hmm this is not a joke this is and I
told him I said if we can do this with
Wakanda forever and make up 1.5 billion
dollar experience for fun we certainly
can do that by tallying a vote tally a
vote we can do that but Condit forever
come on now come on yeah that's that's
fun
well I am I'm gonna see you
any of these films corticon these these
these moments give these Avenger movies
these know maybe um I know this is my
wife's moment right now she's she's a
Conda and the Tom Cruise she did the
Mission Impossible six and you know I
did the mummy and and Tom called and
said court not really want you well I
said you got to do it you gotta do yeah
you gotta do gotta get what Tom it's
great it's gonna be it is a being the
biggest of the the Mission Impossible as
ever you know this one
so you know it's you know we just she
and I we we go where the work is you
know and you got to ride the wave
sometime the wave really takes you on a
ride sometimes it you know and in the in
the interim we we make sure we still do
what we do which is take care of the
family sure Angela Bassett your wife is
she is she watching any of these
football games football baby but you
know it's true
is there anything no like its hoops is
she'd taken in anything she goes with us
to you know we I for the last four or
five years I've gone to the Super Bowls
okay
and take my listen Italy it was my good
brother and I we went and then the kids
said they went my son wanted to go so it
was a guys thing okay
and then my daughter said she wanted to
go so with no it's and the girls wanted
to go okay so so but it was in
Minneapolis last year so the the ladies
didn't want to go cuz it was just cold
Zuko okay um I think next year this year
is gonna be in Atlanta oh they'll be
there wanna go this year do the Patriots
have to go for you to go or or you'll
just go the Patriots will be there okay
then you saw that game okay
Tom's not gonna be denied what about
going down to Staples with LeBron coming
in here you're you're planning a run
that's wrong so my guy how do you mean
LeBron is somebody much like Tom
terrific
is someone who does what is necessary I
mean it's it's it's
it's clear when the last eight finals he
was there no matter I mean the the the
after they took down after being down
3-1 to Golden State and they came back I
said everyone has said you can't say
anything about in the brown you may not
like him but after that it's over it's
over he's the best of all time him and
Michael you by the time LeBron leaves
you it's a toss-up but you can't you
what can you say so the same thing is
gonna happen with the Lakers he'll it'll
take a minute for them to get there
their chemistry together but he's gonna
do the same thing with them I think
again that they are making the playoffs
this year
hit the roster that he currently has is
better than what he had in Cleveland
even though there's no there's no Kevin
Love yeah yeah Robin to his Batman in
Los Angeles yet but I still think that
the that tonight we're gonna begin to
see these young guys with him gel a
little bit faster than expected he makes
you want to play your best game he makes
people want to play better he makes
everybody better and it used to be you
could say he couldn't close our games
you couldn't he does whatever is
necessary to he's a student of the game
he watches he learns he watches film and
this you watch fans you watch mark my
word they will be in the playoffs and
they will be sniffing around the finals
again would be a monumental fir I mean I
you know what I'm saying is this
he doesn't every day he's proven himself
at every level and after he did last
year with the group of guys he had
midseason retooled the whole team yeah
and took them to the seventh game with
seven came in six game it was last year
I noticed I think we went five actually
no no it was well after after you guys
don't remember call that timeout it was
six but go you're gonna do want to get
on the computer in figure but it the
bottom line they didn't get swept just
I'm totally spacing on the right now
bottom line he told Anna to the
yeah this past year they tickets man
yeah it did yeah Junior Smith called
didn't called you're right it was game
one the JR Smith game and the rest of it
was so it was chosen but I understand
what you're saying
you know I understand what you're saying
about LeBrons greatness is there is
there any actor or actress that you've
worked with that's similar and the fact
that you didn't want to disappoint you
will brought out your a-game all the
time
anybody in your career that you could
see that I think that is is like that
like that that you were acting in a
scene with this fellow actor and you're
like okay they're bringing I gotta bring
my A game my why they she's the she
Meryl Streep there's about two or three
Sean Penn there's of course DeNiro Al
Pacino but there's there's nobody like
Angela Angela and Meryl are like that
that she's got a photographic memory and
whatever she does it just blows up so
and she makes everybody we did a play
together first time we worked together
person I think only time we really
worked here was in a huge play at the
Guthrie Theater
his girl Friday and it was 200 pages in
the the John where the playwright was
internally cutting every four days eight
pages so we got it from 200 down to 165
and it was like a rock concert by the
time we got it there was 25 cast members
and she and I were the leads and it was
you know she's she and I both when we
finally got that thing together it was
huge but you know I I knew I didn't I
had to bring my a-game was that everyone
I asked her to do the play
okay well then yeah you better you
better come correct right there and now
do this new film Lucas hedges you and
Julia Roberts call Ben is back about
about her son in recovery for almost 80
days just shows up unexpected on the
doorstep on Christmas Eve and you play
her second husband and this is a son
from her first marriage yes very good
we're blended failing we have two
children of our own and the two other
children from her first marriage and I
basically came in and saved they were in
a trailer park and I believe we met and
I basically rescued the family and the
issue that they're dealing with this is
the son and recovery and and whether to
enable enabling him by allowing him to
to continue on with the drugs or do you
do tough love
it's a I was destroyed by the end of it
I didn't think and cuz I hadn't seen it
when we were at the Toronto Film
Festival I saw it and it literally
destroyed me so towering she's towering
Lucas's towering and the director Peter
Lucas's father actually was hedges is
Peter hedges it's just a monumental film
I'm so proud of it to be in a film
that's really about what's going on in
our world today the opioid epidemic oh
boy so you know it and I think we're all
touched by it I had a my knees replaced
a year ago so ago and you you got to do
some some sort of opioid to actually get
through the pain and forward because I
usually get on and get off of these
things because they're really intense
these these pain medications and I said
you know I had a double one at the same
time I said I'm gonna stay on him for a
month I'm not gonna come off like I
usually do after two weeks or something
you know just just to make sure I can
the pain is gone and by the end of that
month I just came off with him and I
couldn't go to sleep I had like an
anxiety I said this is what they're
talking about sure so and I was just
haunted a month so and I had the intense
pain I said let me so it's it's an
epidemic so I'm I encourage all of us to
to watch and to to really talk amongst
yourselves and talk amongst your your
representatives and then you know we
know this is something that needs to be
dealt with and talked about ban is back
in theatres on December 7th please come
back anytime sir love you let's talk
right back at you
Courtney be Vance at Courtney
events on Twitter and obviously Ben is
back in theaters near you December 7th
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience